well this is actually a perfect session
for homecoming week right we've got the
two of you coming back to Stanford to
share some of your insights
I want to formally introduce Steve
Garrity and Julian Rothenberg Steve
graduated in 2004 and Juliet in 2007 so
it's quite a long time ago and but only
a few years ago it feels like you were
sitting in this audience right here
listing the speakers who are on this
stage so maybe you could give us a
little snapshot of what you've done
since you were sitting here as a student
until you're sitting here on the stage
with me
Steve you might start sure we were
literally just talking about that as we
walked on that it was a strange feeling
to be walking onto the stage from from
this direction but so like Selena said I
graduated computer science in oh four of
five went on to Microsoft I went to
startup first called fortify doing
security work went on to Microsoft's for
a while a software engineer and a
product manager and then started my own
company with another Mayfield fellow
alum Clara Shai called hearsay and that
is going to this day I stepped back from
my day to day job last year there so I'm
still on the board but I took a year off
and I've just been playing which has
been amazing and now I'm working on a
couple of new ideas so they'll be
another company sometime here in the
future
great Juliet so I actually used to help
TA this class so it's particularly
interesting for me because I'm used to
being up here saying hey remember to
turn in your papers and remember to sign
up for dinner and that type of thing so
it's it's fun to be able to take a
different angle on it and then I majored
and I started out management science and
engineering wanted to focus more on
energy so design my own major and an
energy strategy and engineering and then
went off to law school from an
engineering degree went to Harvard spent
three years there you could say started
a company with some folks at MIT
incorporated a science project might be
a more appropriate term and then went to
become a software product manager at Oak
Power which was an energy efficiency
company then went to the Google team
that incubated sidewalk labs Google's
urban and
armed from there went to weigh mo where
I spent three years and launched our
early rider program in Phoenix which is
the way most first experience with
external riders in the cars and then now
I'm at deep mind as Tina said I'm
working on AI for good particularly
focused around energy so the team is the
team that used deep minds AI to reduce
data center cooling energy consumption
by 30 to 40 percent you know it really
strikes me about your backgrounds is
it's only 11 years and 14 years since
you were here at Stanford and you've
done all these different things you know
often students are getting out of school
they're super worried about what's the
first thing they're gonna do and you
realize maybe some of those first things
like you're incorporated science project
you know ends up falling off your resume
you know do not really worry about it
but what we want to focus on today is
kind of a provocative topic and the
topic is finding your superpower now you
know people are often trying to find
their passions and find their place in
the world but we thought it would be
interesting to look at it through the
lens of finding your superpower and so
when I ask that question to each of you
what does that actually mean what is
what is it to have a superpower so when
I think of superpower and when when you
first invited us to this talk I thought
oh crap now I need to find out what my
superpower is but when I when I step
back and thought about it I thought you
know what is it the skill that you
uniquely bring to the table and Tina I
really appreciate leap and its focus on
soft skills because as students it's so
easy to think of a superpower as an
individual effort right it is what am i
great at what am i a rockstar at where
am I gonna get you know constant a
pluses and what could I get a PhD in and
that type of thing but as you get more
and more out into the world it's what is
a unique skill that I bring to a team
and where will I be best when
complemented by other members of the
team and I think within that then it's
what you what you uniquely bring to do
and unique means a couple of things I
think it means you enjoy doing it right
you should enjoy your superpower and be
really passionate about it and then the
other one is that other people should
praise you for it
meaning that they value it and that it's
a valuable thing to bring to others as
well so when I think of superpower
that's how I break it down great
I generally agree with everything in me
Julia had said I think when I was when
he invited us my first thought was like
oh yeah maybe this talk will help me
figure out what my superpower is so I'm
still trying to find it but to me the
superpower is really something about
what can you do significantly better
than most people around you and this is
like what's the thing that you there's a
couple companies that call it what do
you spike on is the term I've heard a
lot but it's classically to me it's what
do you do that you can create an
outsized impact more quickly and so I
think that computer science you talk
about this a lot where like the 10x
engineer right like the best engineers
are 10x more effective not 2x which i
think is a real interesting shift from a
world where if you get into you know the
AI taking jobs conversation at some
point but like physical strength is one
of those things that this the fastest
phosphorus in the world is 2x faster
than everybody in this room not 10x
faster but the smartest person had given
whether it's a machine learning problem
or literature potentially right anything
electrical is actually the distribution
looks very different and you as a
superpower might you having a superpower
might be 10x more effective versus 10
percent well so that's really
interesting does that mean that does
everyone have a superpower I mean is it
that okay we all have something that we
do better than other people that were
uniquely qualified to do what do you
think yeah and then also as part of that
do you
it's a superpower something that's
innate or is it something you build can
you decide I'm going to be a superpower
in computing or in literature or
whatever other topic so one of my
favorite quotes is sometimes attributed
to Einstein although the internet
disagrees with whether he actually said
it or not and it's everybody is a genius
but if a fish spends its entire life
trying to climb a tree it will think
it's stupid and that for me resonates so
much because I think that we all have
these innate abilities and there are
people who are really talented and can
see them and hopefully one of those
people becomes a mentor of yours or a
manager throughout your life and puts
you in a position where you can then
exercise and build on that superpower
and there are things that will
inherently not be your superpower right
like my mom wanted to have a
professional tennis player as a child
and I was born and she looked at the
size of my shoulders and she said well
there
that dream and so there are things that
you can't do and there are things that
you will be good at and hopefully there
will be people who encourage you along
the way who can see the things that you
are great at yeah I think the optimist
in me agrees and says everybody has a
super hour and it's a matter of finding
it and and there's a separate question
of is it valuable just the market value
it I don't know if that's true or not
but I hope it's true I think your second
question about can you choose a
superpower to develop again the optimism
you would like to believe that yes you
can but I tend to lean my intuition says
more it's something that you are
inherently good at that you choose to
focus on because you enjoy it whatever
it just comes easily when I think of
most people I know or supercars that I
can identify in friends of mine
they're often things that they don't
think are very hard I know like you are
exceptionally talented at this
particular thing and like really like I
don't I just thought it was easy yes
money because when I ran my first
company I had this experience where
everybody thought they were doing the
easy job and it was fascinating because
you looked around was like oh my god you
think that's easy to me that would be
really hard and I think that's actually
actually really great when you have a
team where everyone is playing to their
super powers and their strengths and
then everybody feels like they're doing
the easy job so I'm curious I I wonder
if have you figured out at this age what
your superpower is and at what what is
it and when did you figure out what it
was was it something when you were 10
years old you go you know what this is
what I need to be doing or was it 20 or
was it 25 or 30 or 50 you know but
you're not 50 but the point is you know
at what point do you figure it out and
have you figured that so III think the
we're talking of this earlier though the
one that comes to mind for me as what I
think I eventually discovered is a
superpower wasn't obvious to me at first
is it's either like my endurance or my
pain tolerance which is I will just keep
going and long after everybody thinks
that it's worth like stopping or like
it's give up or whatever it's to me it's
kind of like that I just keep going
until you're done with it and at first
that was just kind of a normal part of
what I was around I when I
came to Stanford I walked on to the crew
team not because I was any good at crew
but because they needed people who were
tall and somebody decided that six feet
was tall enough because the team didn't
have anybody that was that tall and so I
started rowing and it the first thing
you learned about crew and no offense
need actual rowers in the room crew is
not a skill sport you basically pull and
then you slide forward and you pull and
he's like there's no like hand-eye
coordination involved there's no tactics
they don't act --ax if you're a
segment there's a very little bit of
skill if you're stroke because you've
got to be very consistent put our wheels
in the back of the boat it's just
literally pull on the or as hard as you
can and that's really it you can
teach anybody to row in about a day and
then the rest of it is how hard are you
willing to push yourself and you know
how small does that pinpoint a light get
before you black out that was very
natural to me freshman year where I was
like oh yeah this is great we're just
gonna row and row and row and row and
then you you know puke into the trash
can on the side of the earth it was
that's crazy that seemed normal to me
and over time I realized that in many
parts of my life whether it was
athletics I'm not built this way I don't
look like this but I'm an endurance
runner and I just enjoy running long
distances and it's because I don't give
up like some fast I don't ever win but I
just don't stop going and then you get
into startups and then one of the
biggest things I think a Paul Graham I
think said this although I'm not sure
the internet would agree startups to
don't die because they ran out of money
startups died because the founders run
out of energy and I think it's very true
like you just keep going keep going keep
going so at first it was obvious at
first it was just that's how I work over
time I've realized I think that's
somewhat weird and unusual and it's a
superpower which maybe makes this of a
bar yeah great okay so do you like
what's your superpower
so my story's a little bit different I
came upon what my superpower was when
someone told me that they used the word
superpower a few years ago and and I
reflected on you know this might be
right it was when I was at way mo and
someone told me you know you learn
really fast and you absorb new
information and it doesn't matter what
type of information that is and and I
thought about it and
I realized yes that is what I like to do
you know I got an engineering degree and
then I went off to law school and I
enjoyed that and then I decided you know
screw all of this my engineering was not
software I didn't take any CS classes in
college I said you know I'm gonna learn
to be a software PM and go go down this
route and work in an entirely different
industry and then there were moments
where I would pivot and do business and
product definition and new industries
that I hadn't ever learned anything
about before and I would you know be
comfortable speaking with world experts
on that very quickly there was one
summer when I was at the Department of
Energy and I sat down it was a summer
internship I sat down at my desk and
they said okay great
your job for the summer is this aspect
of Chinese energy policy and you know
we've got a call in a few hours with one
of the world leading experts on it don't
worry about it you can just start and
you can ask questions and so I said okay
great I got three hours let's see how
fast I can go and I read everything I
possibly could on on the policy and by
the end of those three hours
I knew basically as much as a person on
the call did and it when someone
reflected that back to me that it is my
ability to learn really fast and come up
to speed really fast and get kind of the
80/20 of what is it that I really need
to understand and what's the part that I
don't need to understand that someone
else can contribute that was really
gratifying to me and helped me
understand to the types of roles that I
should be in so Steve you mentioned like
hey I'm great endurance this fits really
well with startups for me because I'm
great at learning fast it's really good
for cross-functional roles and so
product is actually a great role for me
because I get to work with teams of
engineers on designing our technical
infrastructure
I get to work with UX designers on what
does the user experience actually look
like and how do we base that on user
research how do we base that on design
principles I get to work with legal
teams on regulation and on contracts I
get to work with salespeople on deals
and that for me is a really fun and
energizing and doesn't feel like you
were saying it doesn't feel like hard
work because it's oh good there's
something else to save my teeth into and
if you made me do it a hundred percent
of the time I would disengage and be a
lot less excited than if I get to
sprinkle around in a lot of different
areas so do you
once you figure out what you're really
good at and give your superpower do you
have to keep polishing it I mean
something you say you know what all
right I'm really good at endurance I'm
gonna I'm gonna really double down on
that and focus on my endurance or I'm
really good at learning things fast or
I'm good at creative problem-solving or
I'm good at whatever it is and and then
sort of say hey I'm gonna spend a lot of
time working to get even better or do
you just take it for granted and go okay
that's just the way I work I personally
think it's something that you'll want to
work at right because whatever you're
doing in theory you're you're working on
something and if I were in a role where
I weren't leveraged in something that
I'm strong at I think I would feel
pretty demoralized and like I wasn't
contributing as much as I could and so I
think inherently insofar as you're
working on something you should be
leveraging that super power and that
will be polishing it and growing it over
time I think it's implicit like I don't
think you got to work I think you just
you love it you go do it more and the
more you do it the better you get it's
all practice just practice so I'm
curious though there's always this
tension between do you play to your
strengths or do you support your
weaknesses or do you say these are my
weaknesses and I'm gonna go surround
myself with people who complement me how
do you how do you think about that for
yourself and for your team I mean if
there's something I'm not good at should
I go I actually have to go learn this
and get better or to go I'll never be
good at that I just have to have people
around me who help out I think it's and
so for me it's I want to surround myself
with people who are great at things that
are not my core strengths and I want to
consciously be watching them and if we
have a relationship with enough trust
which hopefully if you're working
closely on a team with people you do and
I'll say Steve hey you're really great
at this thing it's something I'm working
on can you coach me on it can you tell
me how you think about it can you give
me opportunities to test this out and
that way I'm not letting the team down
because Steve is there to catch me when
I do a faceplant and I'm also I'm
getting to learn as fast as I can from
Steve yeah I think that's right I think
I don't think of it as a slightly
different metric which is how critical
is this weakness to me and how much do I
really
like how much is it hurting me versus
how much do I just not care about it and
so if it's a really critical weakness
that is impeding your progress in
whatever you're trying to make progress
against whether it's your career or a
relationship or you know a sport or
whatever it is if it's killing you
you've got to go work on it and you
can't just there are some things you
can't accept as weaknesses and still
continue to be successful we're trying
to do and there are some things where
it's not that big of a deal it's easy
it's an easy skill to go recruit or
outsource to somebody or also do
something that like you just don't care
that much about like you don't want to
learn I'm a big believer in what Jay
said are there which is you shouldn't
learn the things that you enjoy and so
if you don't enjoy it and it's not
killing you just ignore it work around
it and just be aware of it right I find
other people who find other people who
can do it fill in the gaps so I'm so
fascinated by something you and I had a
conversation about a year ago about your
thoughts on success and you told me the
story about the messages you tell the
people on your team about doing one
percent better each day and it really
resonated with me and especially around
the idea of being viewed as a superpower
because you often don't see those 1%
things that people do can you can you
describe it cuz I thought it was so
brilliant and insightful yeah there's
this I've no idea where I found this or
heard it but I liked it so much I stole
it and one of our very talented
designers are here so they made these
awesome posters for our office that say
1.01 to the 365 power is 38 and 0.99 to
the 365 power is yeah point zero point
zero two and the point of obviously
being if you make yourself 1% better at
something every day of the year you're
38 times better and obviously if you
slip you're basically zero and I really
like that because it gets to this kind
of idea of iterative improvements which
for so many things in life if not
everything right there's always sort of
the discontinuous changes but there's a
lot of things that you can just if
you're 1% better every day it's amazing
how much progress you make and so if you
can just iterate through things and
figure out how to break it up into
I don't left to move the mountain right
because it's really hard to get started
on moving the mountain it's really easy
to sit there and say like that's really
big I'll do it tomorrow
if you can find a way to do it very
simply today and just make a tiny bit of
progress its compound interest right
like it's the thing that you know your
parents told you ten years ago and you
first gotta check me account
alright compound interest wins and it
just puts into motion yeah it's I think
it's really powerful to think about
those you know 1% things you can do each
day that have a huge compounding effect
what do you what do you think about that
yeah I'm trying to I'm trying to think
about what a 1% when I when I sort of
heard about this I was wondering what
what would have 1% action be right like
or what would a 1% domain be so say that
the area that you want to focus on is
engineering for example like is 1% like
you know learning a new language or
getting code review by someone or
tackling a new problem or I just try and
figuring out how to operationalize it
yeah I think it's a really good question
I think in the engineering examples
event come up with some 1% things if
you're trying to become a better
software engineer right the 1% thing
might be it's not picking up a new
language in a given day but it might
just be literally picking up one new
sort of library or one new design
pattern or what just one little thing
the example I would give that often
given I'm asked about this in terms of
their things is it's thick its keyboard
shortcuts for email if you don't already
use keyboard shortcuts for email learn
them tonight it will take you 5 or 10
minutes and it will make you 10 minutes
faster every day for the rest of your
life and as 10 minutes that you get back
right it's like you may or may not want
to follow this advice I'm a big
proponent of caffeine for getting more
done and if you do the math on how much
more work you get done if you sleep
seven hours instead of eight hours a day
and you can do that without losing
productivity I mean you get like extra
work weeks every year
instead of eight you're like okay so I
start promoting a Red Bull it's a
college students they all drink
identities just don't mix you live odd
guy bad for your heart but there's these
little things in the okay sleep maybe is
one that isn't a good idea
but there's little things that you can
pick up that will just make you a little
bit a little bit simpler right like it
there's another there's a book called
getting things done David Allen GTV that
is it's basically a cult so fair warning
but it's all about productivity hacks
and if you look at this book it's a
collection of little hacks there's
nothing like overarching about it that
is really that different but it's these
tiny little things that will just take
one piece of mental load off of you
right and one of the classic examples
there is like if you have to remember to
bring something with you in the morning
leave it in front of the door before you
walk out like before you go to bed so
you have to trip over it walking out and
all of a sudden you don't realize how
expensive it is to have these background
processing in your head that's like
don't forget that don't forget that wake
up the middle night I'm gonna forget it
if you just if you do one of these
things every day your life just gets
less and less filled with friction I
have lots of 1 presen hacks that have
nothing to do with coding I am a huge
believer in sending thank-you notes
right I mean sending one thank-you note
is a one percent thing that you do every
day and it has a huge huge benefit
meeting one more person right that's a
1% I meet one more person and all of a
sudden it might multiply because that I
need their friends I meet their friends
things like that so I think they're one
present' hacks that have nothing to do
with coding oh absolutely
you of everything in life like there's
always little waste and again that's
that's not to say that there aren't big
discontinuous changes that you make
right and like I would imagine law
school as an example is not a 1% thing
like you don't decide to learn one
percent of the law every day like it's
actually one law day might work like you
actually have to go to law school at
some point and that's a big thing and
it's my guess that's been quite
successful quite helpful for you and
it's been for a lot of people so it's
not that there's no value in
discontinuous changes but this little
kind of improve everyday thing can help
a lot in a lot of realms not just in
train
I would say my favorite one of those is
listening
audio books while I exercise right
because it's like you're getting
exercise you're helping improve your
longevity in your health Steve and and
you're also getting knowledge of
whatever topic that you want so for me
that's I want that's a one percent right
so in a minute I'm gonna open it up to
the audience and I'm going to let you
ask your burning questions so you can
start thinking about that and I want to
use this as an opportunity to sort of
look at the flipside yes we all have
superpowers but I think we also have
fatal flaw right and sometimes we all
know that we sometimes are incompetent
at knowing we're incompetent and how do
you figure out where your flaws are and
how to fix them what's the best way to
address that well I just came off of an
interesting experience so for those of
you who are familiar with the
touchy-feely class at Stanford
interpersonal dynamics I just it you can
take it after Stanford lo and behold
which I found out recently in the minute
that I I found that out I signed myself
up and I took a class where it was me
essentially an eighth startup founders
and leaders in a room for an entire
weekend and got really transparent
feedback about my flaws and I think that
it's and everyone in that room did and
everyone was really open to it and for
me I've discovered actually that I think
along with learning one of my strengths
is getting a lot of feedback and
responding very quickly to feedback and
the way that I do that is by soliciting
a lot of feedback and actually asking
people you know you never realized you
work so closely with people all the time
and you think oh you know what they
think of you but actually if you just
sit down and say okay you know what
screw performance reviews screw the
feedback cycle Steve how can I work
better with you and you know what we
don't have to talk about it in this
one-on-one can you come back next week
and actually put some thought into it
and tell me what are three things I can
do to make our working relationship
better and to help you do your job more
easily you'll learn so much more people
are really nice and performance reviews
because they know that it matters for
your career
and they want they want to help you but
if you actually ask for feedback you'll
get some really honest answers and
you'll get answers like I need you to
back off of one of this area because I'm
actually trying my hardest and you know
I need you to understand that I'm doing
as much as I can do and those types of
answers in context and in situations I
personally find to be so much more
helpful than just generic statements
about oh you know you are this way as
opposed to you have a particular
behavior that if you changed would make
our working relationship much better so
just to follow up so when you get this
feedback is it pretty straightforward to
fix it
I mean those were things that were very
tactical like you know can you back off
were there any feedback you got that was
felt like it was very personal about you
that you thought wow that's that's who I
am that's gonna be something that's
really difficult to change it's possible
I think there are multiple ways to take
feedback right you can take it as that's
who I am and I think there are people
who can give feedback in a way that is
hurtful and so hopefully people will
give you feedback not in a way that is
hurtful but I think you have to trust
someone enough to give you feedback and
then to take it and say okay they're not
you know they're not insulting my
personality they're talking about a
couple of behaviors and they're talking
about I mean someone gave me feedback
recently and and said you know like this
is within like I don't know you outside
of work like this is just feedback
within work I am specifically not
talking about your personality overall
I'm talking about like these specific
behaviors and that's that's really
helpful and I think you need like you
can ask for that but then you can also
mentally talk yourself into this person
doesn't know all of me let me vet that
feedback with others for example one of
the pieces of feedback I got this
weekend that the totally comfortable
sharing is that my emotional range
seemed very seemed very limited in these
interactions that I had sort of one
cadence and write it Steve I don't I
don't know if you know me well enough
for this but when I shared it with
people who I'm close to and when I
shared it with my team at work they said
what you
get really excited and you also you know
get disappointed and you're not afraid
to show when you're disappointed and
you're you know you're pretty human in
who you are and so just being aware to
over the context and vetting out
feedback with other people can help you
not take it as personally and then to
follow up with questions you said that
you know what were the situations that
caused you to say that feedback how
would you have liked to see me behave
differently what suggestions do you have
for things that I can do and things that
I can change I think part of the reason
I'm good at responding to feedback is
because I treat it as almost like user
research and great how many questions
can I have to understand the whole scope
of what's going on here I think for a
lot of people they would think that's a
very brave thing to do you know to ask
for feedback because you might hear
something you actually don't want to
hear that's hard to hear though what do
you think I think that's right and I
think that's the point I think actually
in a funny way what you want to hear
when you ask for feet if you're doing it
right is maybe not the right word but if
you're doing it right then you want to
get stuff you don't want to hear because
of all you hear are stuff that you want
to hear then like it's nice to get
praise it's not that helpful right like
you actually want stuff that's hard to
hear because it's actually the hard
stuff to work on that's impacting you I
have a slightly different not a
different approach to it but we sum that
onto Juliet's theory for this I think
there are people whose superpower is
doing this very well and particularly
they tend to take tend to take roles or
to take roles as executive coaches and
I've worked with I think it's tough when
you build and run an organization to get
feedback very very consistently because
everybody there works for you in some
capacity and so you get less honest
though some say you don't and there are
people who are really good at that sort
of giving feedback to people they work
for but I think it's harder or maybe I
just suck at it and this is one of my
favorite flaws
either way the way I've found to
mitigate this is by hiring executive
coach whose superpower is to go around
get this feedback and then frame it in a
way that is not personal but is also not
taking the edge off it right because
what you want to somebody who can go
through and say hey here's all the stuff
in their head there this person
made this very personal attack and I'm
gonna reframe that to something which is
not like it's okay don't worry about it
but it's also not personal it's it's
here's what I think they're trying to
say and here's you know some ways you
can start to think about working on it
it also gives you a nice hack for
accountability because you have somebody
who can help hold you accountable to the
changes you're trying to make which can
be really hard because these are these
are behaviors you've adopted because
they worked for you for the last ten
years of your life you know it's
interesting I'm just gonna push back on
one thing you said because you said
praise is it useful I would say that
praise is really useful in parallel with
with feedback about that you can prove
because that helps you understand what
you do really well right right so yeah
but if you're if you already know what
you're good at then the feedback is
helpful are those right great so I'm
curious anyone have a question in the
audience okay right over here stand up
please
jaye name but the guys I want to ask you
how mindset of failing fast in something
like actually isn't working and it's
wasting time to keep going are there
times when that concert vision should
actually stop possible I'm gonna repeat
it so the question is okay endurance is
great but sometimes if you're failing
you should just give up and say you know
what let's let's sort of count our
losses and do something different like
when does endurance get in the way yeah
I think that's a very insightful
question and I think there's something
to be said there about to to this point
about not only superpowers but fatal
flaws there's also terms of this concept
right of your biggest strength also is
potentially your biggest weakness and I
think fundamentally I struggle with that
a lot which is it's really easy to keep
going and put your head down and it's
for me it's very hard to to cut my
losses early because I'm like ah I just
try harder I can probably make it work
and like nine times out of ten I can and
the tenth time I waste a lot more time
doing it I think it's something I
have become more and more aware of
overtime and something I try to be
thoughtful about the biggest way I've
found to do that is through basically I
talking to kind of friends and mentors
and caught like outside people because
it lets me divorce the pain from the
like is this likely to succeed or not
because they're not experiencing the
pain generally of me kind of pushing on
for whatever it is and they can either
say like no that looks like you're
almost there or you know know you're
really this is hopeless get out and I
know I'm not bailing cuz like oh man
this is really hard because they don't
care it's hard so but but it's hard and
it's a it's it's something I've made
that mistake many times and pursue
anything is longer than I should of what
do you think so I'm curious Steve when
you when you say that I think with every
good idea there I usually find that
there are about 50% of people who are
constantly who will always say this
won't work and you know me if you're
lucky you get 50% of people who will say
this will work but there there always
are people regardless of how good the
idea is when it's early enough who will
tell you know throw in the towel so how
when you're relying on other people
rather than yourself for that guidance
how do you distinguish between those so
I think it's really important you don't
rely on them you just look for it it's
another signal and say you know hey how
am I feeling about this and how are
these people reacting and it can it
can't be one and then by the way that I
don't know this is the right answer
because I'm so good at this but I've
made me a little bit better at it I
think you look at you know five or ten
people and your track records and you
say hey are these people good at
evaluating this it's a little bit it's
really important to frame the question
correctly right so it's not like is this
idea a good idea or not like in the case
of a startup in my expands like nine out
of ten people are gonna tell you it's a
terrible idea and and the general
thinking there is that if it was already
good it would have happened and somebody
else would have done it and so it's
pretty logical that most people don't
think it's a bad idea so that's a
slightly different one but in the sense
of like I'm in this situation is my
current kind of course and speed gonna
carry me through to where I want to go I
think you can frame it in a way that
more people will give you better answers
but it's still more of a judgement call
right and once that maybe wants that
balance shifts to like 90% of your front
are saying like what are you doing you
know you it's maybe a more time to pull
the ripcord then when you know just a
couple people are amazing it's also
important by the way you get people who
care enough about you but not too much
your parents pretty bad for this you
know it's quite interesting I find that
all the time you know that that it's
better to ask people who are not so
close to situation that they their
judgment is actually class yeah yeah
okay I think there was another question
yes so what do you think that you can
still succeed in that field and if so
which roles or what kinds of things
would you suggest focusing on it until
you're able to get to seeker so the
question is there often times where
you're passionate about something but
you might not have the skills yet to
actually contribute to that field what
are the soft skills or the other
opportunities in that discipline that
allow you to get your foot in the door
as you're building those other skills
that's a fantastic question
definitely soft skills become more and
more important as you move further in
your career right and there's a there's
a point at which it flips and there are
far more important than the hard skills
are I think it is the hard skills don't
necessarily need to be your superpower
but getting those will make your soft
skills so much more credible so for
example I remember being told when I was
in college that I should get the hardest
engineering degree that I possibly could
and I didn't I design my own and I
regret that I regret not digging deeper
into hard engineering skills it it's not
that it would have in my superpower and
I always knew that it wouldn't but I
think if you have those soft skills to
layer on top of it you will always have
opportunities to exercise those soft
skills because life tests your soft
skills each and every day and if you
have at least a certain level of
credibility and harder skills you'll be
able to get past that period and then
your soft skills will start to shine
really quickly so if I
you I would encourage you to go at
getting those hard skills be really
diligent work hard it's going to be a
slog and then allow your soft skills to
shine from there that would be my advice
some of which I took them some of which
I didn't you know it's interesting that
sort of the model that often gets
floated around of the t-shaped person
the person who has a depth of knowledge
and at least one discipline but the
breadth of knowledge and the skills will
allow you to work across disciplines so
it's about thinking of yourself as a
t-shaped person that allows you to
really be successful I agree I think
there's a lot to be said for for
acquiring some of the hard skills even
if they're not your superpower just to
have credibility and knowledge I also
think there's a lot to be said for I
can't think of a time I had any problem
areas or fields where the soft skills
aren't also quite important and so they
might not be as glamorous or as exciting
in the early days of something right but
you can almost always find a way to help
and that gets you involved and that gets
you both building the hard skills and
also more and more kind of expertise in
that area so as you get deeper into your
career you have more and more right and
so you can get into classic kind of you
know that you're starting a technology
company and Stanford where the
technology of interest program and it's
like well you know what is somebody
who's not writing code due in the first
year of a software company there's all a
lot right now it doesn't mean you need
five people who don't have engineering
degrees and one engineer because that
doesn't work out that well but there's a
lot of stuff to do and I don't mean like
kind of dumb stuff right like you know
like yes you need to get an office and
get benefits set up and administrative
stuff but there's actually there's user
research there's partnership
conversations there's fun bunch of stuff
that needs soft skills you can find a
way to help and then over time as the
company grows there's even more and more
need for soft skills and the more that
you have hard skills I would say even in
that role hard skills are really
important because you'll be so much kind
of more credible with engineering teams
and you'll actually understand the pain
and problems that they're going through
and you'll be able to better take back
say user research or fundraising
feedback and in a way that's useful to
the team so hard skills are always
helpful so I think back
over my long career and your short
careers I'm sure that there been people
who've been incredibly encouraging and
some who have been discouraging can you
think of examples of someone at a
pivotal moment who said something or did
something that really allowed your your
passions and your superpower to blossom
because they did or said something at
just the right time that really allowed
that to happen or on the flip side
someone who did just the opposite
there's someone for me that comes to
mind immediately so when I was at O
power I was working in product and the
the core area of the company's product
and having a great time working with a
really awesome team and then someone
came to me and said do you want to join
my team I'm on the innovation team and
we're gonna be exploring a new market
what here's my here's my like rough idea
for it in two sentences that's basically
all I got what do you think and I went
around and I talked to various folks
within the company and every single
person said it will be the opportunity
of a lifetime for you to work for him
and they said part of that was because
he had such a strong super power in
being an idea person he was a really
strong innovator he could see
opportunities but he wasn't very good at
making them definite and bringing them
to concreteness I I once had the
opportunity to talk with a node Khosla
about this and he used an analogy that I
really like which is you know there are
people who define Mount Everest and what
that grand vision is and then there are
people who define what Basecamp is and
what the web-based camp looks like how
to get from here to Basecamp and then
have some idea of how you're gonna get
from base camp to the top of Mount
Everest
and he gave me the opportunity to pair
with him so that I could define what
that base camp was and then help us get
up there and help us get up to the top
of the mountain and for me that was a
pivotal moment because it showed me that
that is the area that I really like that
I'm not gonna be the person who's
defining Mount Everest that's not my
superpower but if we've got an idea I
can define Basecamp and have the hunger
and drive and endurance to go after and
get it and that was really pivotal for
me just because he saw that spark in me
that that would be something that I
could do and encouraged me
go and explore something new and
ultimately I think that's what great
managers and leaders do is they're able
to see what an individual person might
be great at give them an opportunity to
go in and shine in that area so I have a
lot of gratitude that I have some
similar and I've had a lot of people who
are very encouraging the the one that
comes to mind ironically wouldn't you
mentioned that was the opposite was
somebody was very discouraging but
triggered I guess I think was my
superpower about eight eight years ago I
was in a bad motorcycle crash out on
highway 9 and I was riding along with
some friends and a about 16 inch thick
eucalyptus tree fell on my head and I
woke up I was unconscious and they
thought I was dead for a while and I
woke up and one of my buddies like dude
a tree fell on you and I was like that's
really embarrassing I rode my bike into
a tree said no no no it actually fell on
you it was like a it was like a cartoon
like a clothesline me as I rode past
worst part of this whole story is he was
wearing a helmet cam but it was out of
memory so always change your memory
cards on your helmet cam so anyways I
got airlifted to Stanford it turned out
that this tree had ripped two nerves off
my spine and so I couldn't use my left
arm for a while like literally just
wouldn't move it just kind of hung there
and I was training for Ironman at the
time and I was having this conversation
with this I think he was a med student
or maybe a resident at Stanford and I
said like hey like I got to get back to
training not really realizing how
serious this was like when can I start
running again and this guy's like are
you kidding me you're never gonna run
again in your life and my immediate
reaction was like fu what do you know
you're just a doctor and I got stubborn
very quickly and did a bunch of research
and and and found these guys up in
Rochester Minnesota who can reattach
nerves went through a bunch of surgeries
blah blah blah and about a year later
finished my first Ironman post accident
and I finished it significantly faster
than I PR previously before I got
injured and then went on to run longer
and longer races and I never got the
doctors name to go back and follow up
with him but in a funny way I actually
really owe him thank you in a sense
because it literally the reaction was
very immediate
and like know like I'm going to prove
you wrong not only because it's my life
and I want to have use of my arm again
but because like you said I couldn't do
it that doesn't deserve clapping I
surged Isaac sir dies that's amazing but
what endurance and your sister almost
stubbornness that's so great
do we have another question yes over
here what is it that encourages you to
become 1% better it's something that you
might already be so the question is how
do you motivate yourself to get 1%
better even when you already are the
best at what you do in your organization
ultimately for me it comes down to what
what your goal is right like if your
goal is just to get better as a person I
I think that's a good good goal for sure
but ultimately when I'm on a team my
goal is helping our team achieve
whatever our team's goal is and so I
might be the best in the company but
that is completely irrelevant what's
relevant is how can I be the absolute
best and helping go after what our what
our goal is and so I think always having
that benchmark is really important and
it can motivate you and particularly can
motivate members of your team as well
I've been fortunate that I've always
been a member of teams that have a
really clear mission and a really clear
vision and that that can always be used
to inspire people you know every All
Hands and every every team meeting it's
always about what the broader goal is
and how we're going about getting there
and I think the best way to align
yourself to improve is if it's not just
in the service of yourself but it's if
it's in the service of the broader team
call I think that's a really good answer
and purpose and mission I also think
there's a set of people who are just
intrinsically motivated to self-improve
because that's fun entertaining I don't
know exactly what I find that way I just
I like improving because I just there's
something inside my head that's
seedy that's kind of like Oh I'm 1%
faster today like that's a good thing I
don't know how you teach that or build
out an organization other than through
hiring and here's he focused a lot on
hiring people who were who thought that
way and they're just kind of were
believers in continuous improvement for
the sake of just getting better like it
was a noble goal one of the guys I work
with said it really really well and I
quoted all times in mark Gilbert said
that perfection is the goal but it's not
the destination meaning that like you're
never actually gonna get there so you
there's no finish line like you just
keep going but that's kind of part of
the fun part like how boring would it be
if you didn't need to improve anymore
you just sat there I don't know how
you'd teach that to an org I think it's
I think you'd largely drive that through
mission and purpose as opposed to just
telling people to get better okay so I'm
gonna ask the last question so I want
you to flashback to when you were a
student here whether it's 11 years 14
years ago that you were sitting here and
to think what you wish you knew when you
were back here as a student so I've got
one I I I think there's this notion that
you have when you're at Stanford that
the world is your oyster and to lodgest
and it is right it is something that you
can take advantage of because there are
so many opportunities and so many
opportunities to contribute but I also
think there's this notion that life is
going to be up into the right you know
the same as startup returns are and
you're gonna go and you're gonna get the
perfect job after you graduate and
you're gonna have figured out what you
want to do and I think what's the most
beautiful about finding your superpower
and also finding out what you're really
cold to do is that it's a really messy
process and if you want you can be
methodical about this messiness I mean I
haven't read that much of designing your
life but I read sort of 20% of it enough
to it to get the gist and I think that
the idea of testing out different areas
and deciding which one of them is going
to be most suitable for you is a
good one the problem is that when you
find out that an area isn't the area
that you want to go into you have a
moment that where you have to pivot and
pivots are not they're not easy if
you're a startup they're probably just
just as hard if not harder if you're a
person and I think pivot is a nice word
for what this feels like
I prefer been horowitz's with EO acronym
which stands for we're it's over
Tina told me I could square and feel but
it feels like we're it's over
right it's a really harrowing moment
where you think I was on this patent
this is what I was gonna do and this was
gonna be my identity and oh crap it did
not work out what am I going to do now
and those moments feel the scariest but
they don't mean that you're doing it
wrong they mean that you're doing it
right they mean that you tried something
so hard that you really could get a
great insight into whether it was right
for you or not you gave it a solid go
and this applies to all aspects of your
life and then when you're able to pivot
from that and say okay what do I learn
from this and how does it make me
stronger that's where the biggest growth
opportunity happens is it happens in
those moments one of my favorite
meditation teachers says that you know
in meditation the actual part of
meditating is when you figure out that
you're screwing up and your mind is
getting off in your thoughts and then
you bring yourself back to your thoughts
that's meditating and that is life and
that is learning to in the more
us over moments where you're realizing
that you've screwed it up and you need
to find another path and what's that
path gonna be and how are you gonna get
there
and so you know Stanford makes a lot of
things really easy for us I definitely
felt like Stanford was a nice and easy
and safe environment and the real world
can be that way but it also can be more
challenging and and endurance and
perseverance helped but so does an
attitude of willing to learn through
whatever life throws at you and and
being willing to pivot through those
moments thank you I think that's yeah I
think that's awesome and and the the way
I would get the add on to that I would
say is don't take it so seriously
like life is a game
and I find when I was here I was so
worried about what was next that was I'm
maximizing everything and was I improved
my one percent a day and was that going
and and I just the the more I go through
stuff the more I just kind of like let
go a little bit and it doesn't mean you
don't work really hard and doesn't mean
you don't learn a ton of stuff and
doesn't mean you don't go through really
hard stuff because judging absolutely
right like the more of those you go
through the more fun it is at some level
and and at some point you begin to
embrace the suck and just like you know
this is hard and we're it's over
and oh wow okay I feel that that's
comfortable I'm there again like what do
I do next but it's it like enjoy it like
just go through it and have fun and
relax a little bit that doesn't mean you
know go like smoke weed and Tahoe all
year but it's not about its cursing
right
no but it's it's not if it's not to say
you don't don't work hard don't don't
try to excel all these things but like
just enjoy the whole thing and realize
that like there's a bit of chaos to this
all right and I've read just enough
chaos theory to know the name and it's
true like it makes sense everything is
kind of chaotic and you can be the most
put together planned out methodical
intense type-a person and like the
optimal Stanford student like
genetically-engineered Stanford student
and it won't all work and that's okay
like the most interesting some of the
best things I've done in my life have
been things I did merely for the reason
that it seemed like it would create a
good story and like sure enough it did
create a good story that actually turned
out to be really fun and memorable
whether or not I ever told that story to
anybody because it was just fun so so
whatever please join me in thanking our
fabulous guy
you